you me bar beers buzzed wings shots
drunk waitresses packed football Cornell
Hofstra slaughter Ben quick nap at my
place and we hit the kids and no I don't
want to do any of that uh uh which is
why I was joking about doing it just
stop stop just stop doing it you're
going to drive me crazy finals go sit at
my desk and be quiet sorry I annoyed you
with my friendship and I'm also sorry
that a lot of people here for some
reason think it's funny to steal
someone's personal property and hide it
from them
here's a little news flash it's not
funny
in fact it's pretty freakin unfunny here
we're looking for room 247 Agent Jack
danger Agent Jack danger Wow that name
is a badass code for badass so badass oh
wait
cool guy probably expecting it cool not
that was incredible
editor
are you danger Jack danger it's actually
pronounced donger it's derived from a
Dutch word meaning prudence in financial
matters now Jack donger also cool have a
seat I understand you need a little help
from the big boys here at UH spis
Hospice yeah US Postal Inspection
Service founded by Benjamin Franklin in
1772 undoubtedly great man's greatest
accomplishment are you aware that he
helped popularize Parmesan cheese in
America I am the space is the crown
jewel of the law enforcement system 1200
inspectors tackling everything from mail
fraud to the shipment of contraband
fruit and of course occasionally
assisting our little brothers in the
police department
little brothers well I am a federal
agent yours the local cop nothing wrong
with that
we're here because we found this key
whoa yes this sexy beast was used to
open a type of mail box we actually
haven't used in years however there are
a few around town that were never
removed real beauts
I can find out where they aren't send
you the locations that would be great
here my email is uh no email
I graduated from anger management the
same way I graduated from Cornell on
time now I'm back got a second chance
and I'm not gonna blow it so look out to
under Mifflin
I mean look out in a fun way you know
not like I'm gonna hurt you
hey guys guess who's back no need to
thank me
[Music]
[Applause]
that is what are you doing here
my own stunts apparently speaking as a
doctor you should be dead but as person
um that was hilarious
oh it didn't look super cool I think
you're in shock you know what I think I
can do this I'm gonna try together no no
no huh you just cheated death my friends
don't don't try to do that yeah just
yeah yep we're tickling take a mean so
tuna when we get in there let's do a
really good job okay
did that really need to be said well not
everything guys says needs to be said
sometimes it's just about the music of a
conversation whoa why is my girlfriend
here Oh is she that teacher in the white
no she's a part-time frozen yogurt chef
which one is she the one in the green
hoodie wow she's like a guidance
counselor no falling so so probably a
tutor no she's probably now
oh and you know what we don't have a lot
of time so we should probably J Mandy Oh
what are you doing here Andy are you a
student here oh yeah you never told me
you were in high school this is weird I
got a go to Spanish oh my god oh my god
I had no idea well that's not gonna hold
up in court we didn't do anything
illegal except knock over in mailbox
with our friends the issue with the
watermark is very serious absolutely we
teach our students that character counts
should you don't teach it well enough
when your students is a yeah chandi he's
having a real rough day today I want to
take out an ad in your yearbook poll
page two words good luck that's not what
I had in mind take it away Peralta will
do should have done that besides got
some bangin Sousa deep cuts thank God
we're here look there's a box up there
oh yeah that is some sweet and green
curves right there
did you talk to the falafel guy see if
he's seen anything suspicious uh you
should probably let me take lead on this
slob people don't like cops and
everybody loves postal workers they do
that's why the phrase most associated
with bringing goodness into people's
lives is going postal
you're kidding right going postal means
a I know what it means I just said what
it means that's what it means okay well
how's about we avoid human contact
altogether and check out the box
what's the point of that thing tradition
and security plus I'd be lying if I said
it didn't look insanely cool
I wouldn't jackpot it's giggle Pig yes
you've served your country proud little
lady
stop don't teach me God you okay no I'm
rattled
[Music]
[Applause]
I like a thumb you're good you're good
that was great but it's just sort of
it's still a little choppy like but
don't worry it's hard it's been a while
- it's like what oh my god you heard
that I'm so embarrassed I'm so like
rusty but you're really coming along
it's really technically proficient but
you know there's really no heart or soul
in it
really
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
nice sweater-vest dressing very
metrosexual draw that weird mini yeah I
remember it hey I have not seen you in
forever how I think you know what
honestly not so good I want you to look
at something okay I just got back from
Greece and I'm scared I may have
contracted all the fingers boom ba-doom
ba-doom buddy Dawson
Dwight is now gone which is totally
awesome
why was he gone he was such a nice guy
no he was not he was a total douche do
buddy
you